not prince andrew anymore just andrew yo
isn't that crazy yeah
so the former prince andrew has lost all
of his titles we found out what you have
to do to lose your titles yeah
you have to either [ __ ] children
or
or
hit it i think british bankers were
unknighted right
or i'm pretty sure yeah or marry a black
girl or oh mary black [ __ ] children or
[ __ ] a black person and you're no longer
and the black person will get you out
faster real talk you [ __ ] one black
person adios yeah and then i think
princess diana wasn't she [ __ ] a
middle eastern yeah dodie and did did
she get to be princess diana until she
was dead or was she just diana i think
she was dying i think they removed the
princess forcibly yeah really i think
that's what if you believe the royal
family killed her you know i mean
there's a lot of doctors that believe
that actually probably i mean it's not
the craziest killing the royal family's
ever done
right like why would it be crazy for us
to believe that like wasn't there
[ __ ] just beheading people all
the goddamn time didn't king henry
behead wives he was with yeah yeah
that's more understandable what i don't
understand is
that it was way more than this shows
which ones
which one's a divorce
i bet that [ __ ] was easy
though he picked that because he didn't
want somebody else to go through what he
went through he's trying to help out his
people he's a king you got to do what's
best for the kingdom you're going to let
that girl go out there marry another
person drive them [ __ ] crazy too you
ever heard of a job where they protect
your flock you ever heard of a job where
they fire somebody in the first day to
send a message to the rest of the
employees yeah that's what he was doing
oh [ __ ] i had to do that
what did you do that way no i just
suspended on my damn farm it was when i
was managing a restaurant oh really not
but not be a
hey uh hey the owner of the restaurant
told me that i had to do that really and
then that would have the uh the staff
did you good uh
no i didn't farm
i didn't find it if i wish he fired you
on the first day they didn't deserve to
be fired man i didn't think that was
right but he said they'll respect you if
you do that and i was like bro we
serving pasta here buddy legs
i don't need that respect
i don't respect me yeah i'm making 15 an
hour i'm good you don't respect me
that's cool bro can we get this working
yeah you're
right so yeah he lost his titles and
like basically the family came out and
said he's going to be defending himself
as a private citizen and no longer as a
member of the royal family wow
he's guilty
pretty much
his entire idea
sorry his whole identity he grew up with
is now stripped from him and he's just a
regular [ __ ] person all of a sudden
yeah which i guess well he gets to keep
his um
military title oh yeah that's true vice
admiral or something like that but
that is kind of wild because
yeah that is kind of wild man well
apparently in 2019 they still don't
strip some of his titles they like kind
of uh lessen his role somehow i forget
exactly how but in 2019 he gave an
interview where he refused to apologize
for his friendship with jeffrey epstein
he apparently showed like he seemed to
show no remorse for any of the victims
and it was just such a bad interview
that like right there you could have
been like yo let's do something so
here's the one they asked him about the
sweating or something yeah [ __ ]
yeah not pete
the guy has a this is something
interesting about the the princess
andrew dude though though or what his
name is
andrew yeah so andrew so other animals
let's call them other andrews do they
have last names
of york and [ __ ] oh yes of york oh yeah
it's of the place yeah right um he ain't
even that no more is he
i don't know i don't think so
anyway the point is is uh with this guy
i [ __ ] for oh yeah i'm curious what
the the age for consent is in great
britain in america in most places it's
18 years old
it's possible that the girl he slept
with i think virginia guffray is the one
it's possible she was above the age of
consent in the uk
right so she was 17 when they had sex
that wouldn't be
uh what is it called
illegal uh
statutory rape now if she is a sexual
slave and there's all this other stuff
going on that's something completely
different but the actual act of sex
wouldn't technically be illegal in the
uk if the age of consent is less than 18
which i believe it might be 16 16 years
old that's an interesting wrinkle to the
story because what we know about this
story is oh they're having sex with
underage girls epstein's island underage
girls underage underage under end or
underage which to us 16 will be underage
to us it is but there wouldn't be so
does he not get charged for that
and if he didn't know if there's no way
to prove that like he paid for it if it
was as simple as like oh yeah this
girl's into you now it's he says she
said yeah that's if she's the only girl
yeah which i think i don't think there's
more girls
and that's why they're officially going
all right we got to separate ourselves
you notice this happens after is guilty
and after they say that she's gonna uh
drop the list of eight john does yeah so
she comes out and technically i think
she's saying that i'm gonna remove the
uh desire to object from their naming
yeah i thought it was kind of a
half-assed thing yeah so it's not
technically like i guess can you explain
i don't necessarily understand it
completely but like basically if you're
in a legal proceeding and there are
people in your case that aren't actually
being charged but they're technically
connected you have a ability to
basically object to their name being
publicized
so you can object to it because your
attorneys think that it'll actually
proceed like the justice procedure or
whatever
but
now she's saying i'm not going to object
to that so they could say the names and
she's not going to say they weren't
there exactly but she's not necessarily
going to confirm that they were she's
not coming out saying yo this is what it
is she's just now instead of john doe
it's andrew prince ender of york or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah so whatever the
names come out and then it's possible
that like the actual courts might not
publish the names either yo i don't know
if they should be able to take away his
titles because the titles are what got
him to [ __ ] them little girls if he was
just andrew
right if he was just regular old andrew
of york or whatever like that epstein's
not connecting with him and then serving
him up the underage box right
what happened was he was the prince and
it's like how can we get involved in
that family and potentially incriminate
that family so that we could manipulate
some things that we need to
so that title is what put you in that
position you got to take that you the
royal family you gotta take that that's
prince andrew bro i wonder if they're
trying to defend him we take all your
titles maybe that helps you in quarters
i think it's a pr move for them because
he's not pretending protecting
themselves but i hear what you're saying
like yeah if he's just a guy it doesn't
seem as crazy as like the royal family
if it's tough to prove he's probably
gonna be found not guilty and then he's
still living in [ __ ] buckingham
palace probably got all the access to
whatever he wants
does he and you gotta be for that
[ __ ] bro cause you're andrew in
new york i'm andrew son yeah all right
new and improved very much improved 100
andrew of old york looking he's from the
he's from the old york yeah you know we
give a [ __ ] about that
y'all never go to england and go visit
your
new york is so much better than old york
ain't [ __ ] in old york bro yeah they
don't have a queens i guess they have
one queen but they don't get one queen
we got queens technically
they take his money also right
like they
oh now he doesn't get like a stipend
but he's bred it all these [ __ ]
yeah like they set them up they give
them inheritance they got they're good